[Music]
all right new york city restaurant
owners are fighting back big time
against mayor de blasio's ridiculous
vaccine mandate our next guest sued de
blasio over the indoor dining band back
in december and is taking action again
irene cyrakis is the owner of the famous
kellogg's diner in brooklyn she joins us
now irene now they want you to show a
vaccine card
and if you are got caught with someone
eating at your restaurant without a
vaccine card thousand bucks two times
two thousand bucks how do you feel about
that
um i feel that my uh liberties have been
taken away from me my civil liberties
have been taken away from me
um i feel like i don't have the right to
feed my children
i feel
fear
that they're they're in
this mayor has just put danger in my
life
he's creating division
and he's he's going to create violence
this is not going to be good
so you told me you're angry right you
told me that you you know you saw it in
people's eyes they don't want to be
asked about their health their vaccine
status and you have to be on the front
lines what's the reaction you're getting
from the people in brooklyn
so
the stare the stare at the door
is putting fear in in me
i i just i i feel it and one person
actually said to me you better not
refuse service to me
and it just shook me
this is exactly what i'm afraid of
and um
our mayor
really thinks in his demented mind that
he's doing something good here
he's not
he's creating he's going to create more
violence he's going to create more crime
with this
liberties you're suing correct i have to
so you have to so you got to pay for a
lawyer and you're suing again you're
suing this this city
correct we're suing the city we're suing
mayor de blasio
um
because he is
he's not letting me
run my business
with all the rights that i have
i you know i i already have a 1.4
million judgment against me from the
first mandates that our governor and our
mayor put on us the first time around
and now this they're breaking me right
that's exactly what they're doing don't
let them they're breaking us and you're
taking it with four kids unbelievable
okay i am not complying i'm not
complying brian well we're not
complaining i can continue to come here
irene i'm gonna have to leave it there
but i continue to come here i'm so glad
you're taking action uh because now the
clipboard police are going to come up to
you and start hitting fines with you uh
and let them deal with the customers
irene cyracus the owner of kellox diner
find a way to get down there and
patronize that place irene thanks so
much
thank you brian thank you so much you
got it we reached out to mayor de
blasio's office for comment but we did
not hear back mainly because he sleeps
till about 11. uh